[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Es ist schon eine Weile her,
aber ich hatte euch mal in meinen Stories gezeigt,
wie ich Joghurt selber mache.
Meine Mama, die macht das im Prinzip schon immer so.
Also Mama macht immer den Joghurt selber.
Sie isst gar keinen gekauften Joghurt,
weil er ihr am besten schmeckt.
Ich mag aber auch ganz gerne den Sahnejoghurt.
Ich esse den wirklich supergerne.
Aber ich esse auch gerne selbst gemachten Joghurt.
Ich zeige euch heute wie.
Und ihr braucht im Prinzip nur zwei Zutaten.
Zum einen ist es nämlich Milch.
Da nehme ich jetzt einen Liter.
Und zwei Esslöffel Joghurt.
Entweder nehmt ihr da jetzt einen Sahnejoghurt
oder ihr nehmt einen selbst gemachten Joghurt.
Also ich habe jetzt hier auch ein bisschen
selbst gemachten Joghurt von meiner Mama.
Ich kann aber auch den hier benutzen.
Oder ihr nehmt Joghurtferment.
Das ist aber ein bisschen schwieriger zu bekommen.
In Reformhäusern oder auch online ist es zu kaufen.
Aber, wie gesagt, nehmt einfach einen Sahnejoghurt,
wenn ihr es stichfest haben wollt,
oder auch ganz einfach einen anderen Joghurt.
Bei Naturjoghurt könnt ihr gerne
zwei, drei Esslöffel mehr benutzen.
Und ansonsten war es das schon.
Was ihr wissen müsst, ist,
dass die Milch, die ihr verwendet, die ist ganz wichtig.
Entweder nehmt ihr Frischmilch vom Bauern
oder ihr nehmt einfach hocherhitzte Milch,
die es eben im Tetra Pak gibt.
Ich habe hier jetzt auch die Tetra-Pak-Milch.
Und die Tetra-Pak-Milch, die ist ja schon erwärmt.
Das heißt, die ist ja schon ultralange haltbar.
Und da gibt es noch diese Frischmilch, die es gibt.
Die ist sieben Tage haltbar.
Und da ist einfach nur wichtig,
dass die Milch einmal dann praktisch erwärmt wird
auf 95°C für etwa fünf Minuten,
damit einfach alle Bakterien abgetötet werden.
Die Eiweißstruktur verändert sich dann auch,
dass eben der Joghurt gebildet wird.
Aber bei der Tetra-Pak-Milch
da ist das alles im Prinzip schon erledigt.
Ich werde es jetzt gleich trotzdem erhitzen.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt hier meine Milch.
Und jetzt füllt ihr einfach eure Milch in einen Topf
und könnt entweder ein Thermometer benutzen
oder ihr geht so ein bisschen nach Gefühl.
Ich mache es jetzt tatsächlich mit einem Thermometer.
Ich habe jetzt hier einen Topf.
Da kann ich es reingeben
und direkt so ein kabelloses Thermometer anschließen.
Das ist einfach mit meiner Kochstelle verbunden.
Aber ansonsten könnt ihr nach Gefühl gehen.
Und es muss bis 95°C erhitzt werden,
das heißt bis kurz vor dem Kochen.
Also so, dass die Milch einfach nicht überkocht,
fünf Minuten erhitzen.
Wie gesagt,
bei Tetra-Pak-Milch ist das eigentlich nicht notwendig.
Macht es aber gerne trotzdem.
Ich verbinde jetzt einfach kurz mein Thermometer.
Dann muss ich nämlich nicht darauf achten.
Aber, wie gesagt, einfach erhitzen bis kurz vor dem Kochen
fünf Minuten lang, das geht natürlich auch.
[Musik]
90.
Ihr könnt ansonsten auch gerne
so ein manuelles Thermometer benutzen.
Das könnt ihr dann so reinstecken
und einfach auf die Temperaturanzeige achten.
Aber, wie gesagt, 95°C ist gerade so der Punkt,
an dem die Milch eben nicht überkocht.
Also von daher erkennt man es so auch ganz gut.
Während die Milch jetzt hier gerade noch warm wird,
könnt ihr auch schon mal eure Gefäße desinfizieren.
Das heißt, einfach kurz auskochen
in heißem Wasser im Topf
oder kurz im Dampfgarer im Backofen,
sodass sie wirklich schon steril sind,
damit ihr euch da einfach keine Keime und Bakterien reinholt
und der Joghurt eben auch schön fest wird.
Das ist wirklich wichtig!
Bei mir ist jetzt die Milch auch gleich warm.
Ich warte noch kurz zwei, drei Minuten.
Und dann geht es hier gleich weiter.
Jetzt kommt der beste Part bei der Joghurtherstellung!
Nämlich Kaymak.
Mmh!
Wenn meine Mutter immer Joghurt macht,
bis heute noch liebe ich es,
diese obere Schicht, diese Rahmschicht so wegzulöffeln.
Und jetzt muss die Milch wieder herunterkühlen
und zwar auf etwa 50°C.
Und, wenn ihr da jetzt kein Thermometer habt,
wie wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch,
dann wartet ihr einfach jetzt und rührt immer wieder schön um.
Und meine Mutter hat immer gesagt:
"Hände waschen.
Und dann den kleinen Finger nehmen
und in die Milch stecken.
Und, wenn die Milch etwas wärmer als handwarm ist
und einfach so kurz vor dem Verbrennen des kleinen Fingers,
ist sie so etwa bei 50°C
und dann ist die Temperatur perfekt."
Also es darf nicht zu heiß sein,
weil dann einfach die Joghurtbakterien nicht funktionieren,
aber auch nicht zu kalt.
Und gerade so um 50°C rum
vermehren sich die Joghurtkulturen eben am meisten.
Und daher möchte man auch diese Temperatur erreichen.
Also warte ich jetzt einfach, bis es schön abkühlt.
Wer sicher gehen will,
nimmt, wie gesagt, wieder ein Thermometer.
Aber es funktioniert auch alles ohne.
Also Joghurt herstellen macht man schon seit Jahrtausenden,
auch schon immer ohne Werkzeug, ohne Technik.
Wenn ihr sie habt, könnt ihr sie nutzen.
Wenn nicht, dann einfach wirklich auf die Tipps achten
von meiner Mama.
Ich nehme jetzt aber erst mal den Rahm raus
und esse den nämlich auf.
[Musik]
Oi!
Das ist das Beste!
Das ist wie so Puddinghaut.
Manche mögen es und manche nicht.
Aber ich liebe es!
Aber ist noch ein bisschen heiß.
[Musik]
Mmh!
Übrigens habe ich hier jetzt
eine 3,5-prozentige Milch genommen.
Wenn ihr den Joghurt cremiger haben möchtet,
also so ein bisschen satter und voller,
könnt ihr gerne noch einen Becher Sahne zufügen.
Meine Mama macht den Joghurt auch immer gerne
aus 3,8-prozentiger Milch.
Wenn ihr aber sagt,
"Hey, ich möchte gar nicht so viel Fett drin haben",
dann könnt ihr auch eine 1,5er Milch nehmen,
1,5-prozentige Milch nehmen.
Wie gesagt, je mehr Fett umso cremiger.
Aber es hat mit der Stichfestigkeit später
eigentlich relativ wenig zu tun.
Jetzt hat die Milch die perfekte Temperatur.
Wie gesagt, ihr könnt es mit dem Thermometer überprüfen,
50°C,
oder den kleinen, sauberen, gewaschenen Finger
in die Milch reinhalten.
Und die ist jetzt wirklich so, dass ich so denke:
"Okay, mein Finger verbrennt gleich." Aber
ich kann ihn trotzdem ganz gut darin halten.
Also nicht zu heiß und nicht zu kalt.
Kurz
Finger waschen.
So.
Und dann nehme ich jetzt einfach meine Joghurtkultur,
also aus meinem Joghurt hier.
Der von der Mama, der ist auch echt gut.
Aber ich glaube, ich nehme jetzt doch den.
Und mit Mamas Joghurt mache ich dann einfach später
noch mal eine Portion Joghurt.
Denn bei uns wird Joghurt echt oft und viel gegessen.
Also einfach jetzt zwei Esslöffel Joghurt reingeben.
Schön verrühren.
Und bei diesen 50°C
vermehren sich die Joghurtkulturen, wie gesagt, am besten.
Und entweder füllt ihr jetzt
die Masse in ein großes Gefäß ein
und habt dann einfach ein Joghurtgefäß
oder ihr nehmt viele kleine.
Und ich habe gerne viele kleine.
Dann können wir jeden Tag so eine neue Portion
nämlich einfach anlöffeln.
Und die Kinder essen auch gerne den Joghurt
einfach so aus dem Glas.
So. Jetzt habe ich hier alles schön verrührt.
Jetzt hole ich meine sterilisierten Gläser aus dem Backofen.
[Musik]
Gut.
Und jetzt kann ich hier die Joghurtmilch eingießen.
Ich nehme jetzt ein paar Emailleschälchen.
In der Türkei wird Joghurt nämlich immer traditionell
in so kleinen Emailleschälchen
oder in so kleinen Tontöpfchen serviert.
Und dann nehme ich noch ein paar Weckgläser,
aber ohne Gummi.
Also ich mache die einfach mit dem Deckel dann zu.
[Musik]
Ich gebe jetzt hier noch die Deckel drauf.
Einfach locker drauf legen ohne Gummi dazwischen.
Die Emailleschälchen lasse ich jetzt sogar offen.
Denn ich bereite den Joghurt jetzt im Dörrautomaten zu
bei 50°C.
So kann ich nämlich konstant die Temperatur halten.
Ihr könnt das aber auch natürlich ganz ohne Technik machen
und einfach den Joghurt geschlossen
in ein schönes Handtuch einwickeln,
gerne auch noch unter die Bettdecke stecken.
Also hier ist jetzt einfach nur wichtig,
dass über vier bis fünf Stunden hinweg
der Joghurt einfach schön warm bleibt,
damit sich die Joghurtkulturen wirklich schön vermehren.
Aber auch nicht zu heiß.
Das heißt, ihr könnt auch
den Backofen gerne vorheizen auf 50°C,
dann abschalten und dann den Joghurt hineingeben.
Und ich probiere es jetzt einfach mal
einmal mit Deckel, einmal ohne.
Denn im Dörrautomaten habe ich noch den Vorteil,
dass ja auch die Feuchtigkeit entzogen wird
und der Joghurt sozusagen auch schön stichfest wird.
Und vor allem wird dann die Flüssigkeit,
die sich oben gerne oft absetzt,
einfach mit weggesaugt.
Ja.
Es gibt auch Joghurtautomaten.
Ich glaube ihr habt da einen daheim, gell, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aber, ich glaube, damit kann man dann nur Joghurt machen?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich hatte das noch nie.
>> JOSH: Ich habe nur Joghurt darin gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Weil meine Mama, die hat das, wie gesagt,
immer einfach nur in ein Tuch eingewickelt schön kuschelig
und dann in den Backofen gestellt.
Und das funktioniert natürlich auch.
Aber da ihr immer fragt:
"Was kann ich denn so alles
mit dem Dörrautomaten machen?"
Joghurt könnt ihr zum Beispiel auch machen.
Also hier rein
und dann
nach der Wärme-Kuscheleinheit vom Joghurt
– also wirklich so etwa jetzt vier, fünf Stunden
mindestens drin lassen, gerne auch elf Stunden.
Und danach kommt der Joghurt
einfach für etwa zwölf Stunden in den Kühlschrank,
damit er schön fest wird und kalt wird.
Und dann könnt ihr ihn essen
und probieren.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Jetzt heißt es einfach nur noch abwarten.
Mein Joghurt war jetzt
für etwa sechs Stunden im Dörrautomaten
und er ist auch wirklich schon fertig.
Also, wenn ihr es ohne Dörrautomaten
und ohne Backofen macht,
einfach nur in einem Handtuch macht,
dann lasst ihr den Joghurt am besten wirklich
elf bis zwölf Stunden einfach schön erst mal warm.
Und dann kühlt er ja sowieso von alleine ab,
da man ja keine Technik benutzt.
Und danach stellt ihr ihn noch mal
für zwölf Stunden in den Kühlschrank.
Und dann ist er wirklich schön kalt
und kann sofort verzehrt werden.
Bei mir ist es jetzt so,
der ist jetzt wirklich schön stichfest geworden.
Und es macht tatsächlich keinen Unterschied,
ob mit oder ohne Deckel.
Ich stehe jetzt nur auf der falschen Seite.
Aber ihr seht schon,
hier ist wirklich auch keine Flüssigkeit drauf,
ganz wenig nur,
weil einfach der Dörrautomat
die ganze Feuchtigkeit rauszieht.
Und, wie gesagt, sechs Stunden war er jetzt ungefähr drin.
Er ist schon schön stichfest,
aber natürlich noch warm.
Das heißt, ich lasse den jetzt kurz abkühlen,
dann kommt er in den Kühlschrank
und, sobald er dann kalt ist, können wir ihn verzehren.
Und im Prinzip könnt ihr euch aus diesem Joghurt
jetzt immer wieder Joghurt züchten.
Das heißt, am besten hebt ihr ein Schälchen
immer für die Weiterzüchtung auf
und den Rest könnt ihr vernaschen.
Unsere Kinder, die essen Joghurt.
Also meine Mama, die macht immer
ein Kilo Joghurt pro Woche.
Und das eine Kilo, das ist dann auch immer gut weg,
weil die Kinder einfach viel essen.
Und wir machen da
zum Beispiel auch gerne mal frische Früchte rein
oder essen Joghurt zum Müsli.
Wir essen Joghurt aber auch gerne zu vielen Hauptspeisen.
Ihr kennt ja meine Videos
und wisst, wie sehr und wie viel Joghurt wir verzehren.
Von daher ist es jetzt echt ein ganz cooles Video geworden,
glaube ich.
Falls ihr noch Fragen habt,
schreibt sie gerne in die Kommentare.
Falls ihr noch Tipps und Tricks habt, auch gerne natürlich.
Und dann hoffe ich, dass euch das Video gefallen hat.
Und ja, dann sehen wir uns wieder beim nächsten Mal.
Tschüssi!
Ich würde ihn jetzt am liebsten schon anlöffeln.
Aber er ist halt noch warm.
Aber schon gut stichfest.
Ich löffle ihn dann für euch an, wenn er schön kalt ist, okay?
Jetzt ist der Joghurt richtig schön fest und kalt.
Und wir probieren ihn.
Und ich nehme mir dazu den Josh.
>> SALLY: Josh,
>> JOSH: Ich komme.
>> SALLY: bitte komm in die Küche
und probiere den Joghurt mit mir.
[Musik]
>> JOSH: So.
>> SALLY: Ich habe hier sogar einen rosa Löffel für dich.
>> JOSH: Boah!
>> SALLY: Aber da ist auch schon ein goldener.
>> JOSH: Ich glaube, ich nehme den goldenen. Ist das okay?
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also...
>> JOSH: Ich bin gespannt.
>> SALLY: Oh, was ich liebe, ist,
– guck mal – diese Haut obendrauf.
Bei deinem ist es aber nicht.
>> JOSH: Okay. Der war jetzt schon halt angestochen.
>> SALLY: Nee. Bei dir ist es auch nicht,
weil bei dir der Deckel drauf war und bei meinem nicht.
>> JOSH: Ach, okay. Und das ändert das dann mit der Haut?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Ah, okay.
Also dann kann man sich selber aussuchen,
ob man die Haut mag
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: oder ob man es lieber so direkt schon. Okay.
Ah, cool.
Ich glaube, ich finde den so besser persönlich.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich mit Haut.
>> JOSH: Okay. Na dann.
[Musik]
>> SALLY & JOSH: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Richtig schön mild,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: finde ich.
Superlecker!
>> SALLY: Richtig mild!
>> JOSH: Ich mag das gar nicht, wenn Joghurt so sauer ist.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: So – oft, wenn man ihn kauft,
ist er manchmal so ein bisschen mh.
>> SALLY: Ja, ja.
Und, wenn er mild ist, dann ist oft Zucker drin.
>> JOSH: Genau.
>> SALLY: Und hier nicht.
>> JOSH: Und der schmeckt einfach nur schön leicht.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Echt angenehm.
>> SALLY: Leicht und trotzdem stichfest.
>> JOSH: Ja.
[Musik]
Also superlecker!
>> SALLY: Cool!
Zeig mal bei dir die Konsistenz.
>> JOSH: So. Ist schön.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Bei dir ist er ein bisschen weicher.
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ich glaube, es liegt auch daran,
dass bei dem nämlich der Deckel drauf war
und dann die Feuchtigkeit eben nicht entzogen wird
im Dörrautomaten.
Und hier bei den Emailleschälchen,
da wird ja die Feuchtigkeit noch entzogen,
weil es ohne Deckel war.
Also könnt ihr wirklich dann selber aussuchen,
wenn ihr mit dem Dörrautomaten arbeitet.
Wenn ihr komplett ohne arbeitet,
sowieso immer mit Deckel arbeiten,
damit eben auch nichts dran kommt.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen
eures eigenen Joghurts!
[Musik]
War das ein richtiger deutscher Satz?
>> JOSH: Eures eigenen...
>> SALLY: Mit eurem
>> JOSH: Mit...
>> SALLY: eigenen Joghurt.
>> JOSH: Wird schon passen.
>> SALLY: Es passt.
>> JOSH: Schmeckt lecker!
>> SALLY: Macht euch den Satz einfach so, wie er passt.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und die Mädels, die essen den übrigens ganz gerne
entweder mit Erdbeermarmelade
oder einfach zerdrückten Erdbeeren
Also kann man sich ja selber Fruchtjoghurt machen.
>> JOSH: Das ist auch gut.
>> SALLY: So einen eigenen kleinen Fruchtzwerg.
>> JOSH: Großer Fruchtzwerg.
>> SALLY: Großer Fruchtzwerg,
kleiner Fruchtzwerg.
Tschüss!
>> JOSH: Tschüss!
[Musik]